I know you work on this show Dave's old
porn yeah this is the most porn show
I've ever done in my life everybody's
talking about porn it just cuts in the
air tonight I don't know what amazingly
it's in the air it's on my chin it's
everywhere I love it you know it's funny
about porn is that like you got a lot of
young audience here like those two
superhot chicks that you saw over there
with the thing about point is that like
everybody has their porn like what they
like yeah what you like and I have to
say I like retro porn which is very
hairy dirty filthy porn from that 70s
and 80s like it's it's it's badly lint
horribly lit very cheesy the acting is
out of control and if it's like really
hairy like you know that you're Swamp
People like it looks like that look it
looks like a vacuum cleaner bag exploded
in your face and you're like wow if this
instagrammed or why I was just thinking
about stuff I know that is a picture
isn't it so so so okay you're working on
this show a hurricane hits did you guys
lose power I mean well how do you make
this show happen by candlelight now let
me tell you anything porn to candlelight
there is something so wrong with that I
mean I'm sure every time I was editing
the porn with the candles on like an
Amish guy fell down or something it was
like good evil times in Hell or
something was it bad all right well what
is the biggest you designed the band
love it good they know exactly what
you're talking about I'm curious you
might be now the world's expert on
pornography Jonas as part of this show
you watch you watch thousands of hours
of pornography look at it look at this
hand
yeah and that manipulates different
equipment right okay yes you're right
Kona I watched tons of porn you watch a
lot of pornography I say pornography you
say porn adult films let's meet it
halfway there I don't cinema erotica I
like when they use a rock erotica whoo
opteka really that's erotica like it was
made by a wizard okay is it what is the
difference that you have found between
the pornography the adult cinema of
yesteryear of Molden times and today
what's the biggest difference say in the
last 25 30 years
well the I would have to say that there
the porn of yesteryear of course a hairy
dirty filthy mess you know and the cool
thing about it is like today's porn they
are like athletes like they are tan they
are waxed they are bleached okay they're
ready to go they're hairless and they
are into they're in it to win it
yesterday Sports is like guys that look
like me you know just going at it until
the drugs show up basically it's fine
but there are some classics that like
hold up through time like of course we
all know and
[Applause]
Adagio or Allegro it always works faster
slow for the you know muses Etta stone
people out there exactly and I would say
the coolest thing is cowgirl cuz like
I'm old now and like if you're an old if
you're an older guy you want the woman
to do as much work as possible like I
like when the girls on top because my
job and cheese on top is not to die
that's a lie if they do yeah your job as
this sexual partner is not to die I
don't for it you're fine that's sorry to
take you down or not no no this shows
very classy yeah but then there's
reverse cowgirl reverse cowgirl
yeah revert that's when cheese yeah and
I don't know who invented that but they
were ugly cuz it's like I don't wanna I
want to have sex with you but I just
don't want to look at you you know a
fugly moment if you will but the cool
thing about reverse cowgirl is as a dude
you have to believe in yourself because
it does look like she's getting up to
leave it really does look like hey
[Applause]
all right we we of course closed wrong
now always close strong